de la clarinette oui mais de la
clarinette klezmer
ce petit-fils de clarinettistes a
découvert sa passion à 5 ans en écoutant
pierre et le loup de prokofiev premier
prix de clarinette au conservatoire de
paris en 1997
young s'est spécialisé dans look laisse
mère tradition musicale des juifs
ashkénazes datant du xvème siècle la
clarinette klezmer contrairement à ce
que beaucoup de gens pensaient pas donc
un instrument spécial c'est vraiment une
manière de jouer en utilisent des
clarinettes totalement entre guillemets
classique
c'est vraiment dans la manière de jouer
ce qui est intéressante l'espère par
rapport à la à la clarinette classique
c'est la sueur expressivité c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est à dire que la musique
klezmer klesmer c'est la contraction de
deux mots et brooke les cmr qui veut le
dire
pour instruments et voix et donc on doit
avec l'instrument imiter la voix
guillaume était de passage à la merise
de trappe vendredi 19 février pour un
concert à la croisée des musiques juives
orientale et moyen-orientales ses
influences importantes pour lui explique
en partie son nom de scène
yom mot signifiant jour en arabe et en
hébreu inspiré par l'épisode de la
sortie d'égypte des juifs
yom livre sur scène son dernier album le
silence de l'exode
c'est donc le lait ce qu'on appelle
l'épisode de la sortie d'égypte et donc
l'exode de tout le peuple juif sorties
sorties d'égypte et errant dans le
désert du sinaï mais je tiens à ce qu'il
y ait vraiment toutes sortes
d'interprétations possibles moi c'est ce
qui m'a donné envie de composer cette
pièce mais après c'est quand même un
travail sur l'exode le déracinement
l'errance en général une errance mise en
musique avec des cordes frottées à
l'archet et des percussions persanes
mélodique un mix d'instrumentation
proposé par le contrebassiste claude
tchamitchian le violoncelliste farid des
et le percussionniste bijane chemirani
c'est un album mais c'est aussi une
pièce dire que l'album c'est là ça c'est
mon seul album qui est une copie absolue
de ce qu'on fait sur ses terres que moi
j'ai écrit une pièce qui dure une heure
avec des improvisations un certain
moment donc on la joue jamais deux fois
de la même manière mais la structure est
vraiment extrêmement fixe et on a
enregistré le disque exactement comme on
ferait un concert